yeah how are we going to get her to pose
nicely does that look nice
yeah she looks like she's being held
against her will no
[Music]
i let me get i just finished getting
ready i straightened my hair did my
makeup what do we think do we like
picked out this outfit cuz we're gonna
be taking christmas photos holiday
photos for the very first time as a
family i'm really looking forward to it
but before i head downstairs to take
these photos i want to give a quick
shout out to our sponsor step and step
in case you haven't heard is a brand new
banking platform specifically designed
to help your teen build credit it's
pretty cool because i got isaac his own
step visa card and it's pretty cool
because you can customize whichever
color you want to get for your teen too
it's really awesome every time isaac
uses this it's building his credit
that's amazing
and i can also monitor everything he's
doing within the step app i can set up
recurring payments to give him his
allowance or to pay him for chores like
it's so versatile and i absolutely love
the fact that it's actually helping him
build credit at 13. that's amazing the
cool thing about this step visa card is
that it acts like a credit card but it
functions like a debit card because i
get to manage what money gets put in
here what i get to see what he spends
and help him learn how to be financially
responsible so if you click the link in
the description you'll get ten dollars
when you sign up for step so make sure
you click that link get your teen
started isaac has been so loving this
independence with this card highly
recommend it um especially if you have a
teen anyway let's head downstairs and
take some holiday photos i'm actually
really looking forward to this because
we've never done this before especially
with our cats we've never taken family
photos with our actual kittens
and i actually love how we're starting
to do this now with
the baby coming we're starting this new
tradition
this is like a super last minute
spur-of-the-moment decision just today i
found out that we're gonna be taking
these photos
because uh we actually have our neighbor
ryan here
thank you ryan thank you ryan he is
gonna be he's gonna be taking our photos
for us and i'm gonna be creating some
like holiday cards
for the first time ever like we're
actually gonna be that family you
excited
yeah you've been wanting this too huh
baby yes you're just like yeah can we
can we be like a normal family like can
we just have a normal kind of christmas
decoration what is it christmas
traditions that's the word i'm trying to
say now we gotta get that cat
and sit down and take these photos casey
is struggling trying to keep maya this
one's wild we just clipped their nails
by the way yeah we trimmed all of their
nails
or their claws wow yeah how are we going
to get her to pose nicely does that look
nice
she looks like she's being held against
her will
zoe is is more of a chill boy especially
with the treat he's like okay i'll
listen
look at you you're like a little doggy
good job zoe please cooperate you also
have catnip on sandwich look at that how
cute
he's grabbing it and maya is just not
responsive at all she doesn't care about
the treat no she just wants to get out
of here
she wants to get natal
i'm gonna set you guys down somewhere
and you guys can watch me okay i'm out
of breath we're gonna do this
dang look at all this
i just lint rolled isaac and casey all
the cat stuff because then when the cats
freak out they they shed more and i have
one on my lip zo leaned in
and accidentally got all my lipstick on
his forehead and he got fur on my lip
that was cute am i done no i think i so
i have cat hair on me yep you should
wear tickles that tickles come on
you gotta just withstand it buddy i wish
i could limp roll my lips i feel i feel
fur everything i'll let roll your lips
[Laughter]
we have a guest oh yeah right and a
child
present all right
okay
i think we got something you guys we did
it
on this treat now he's like i can stay
yeah it was so funny because we were
just trying to get some last shots of
the cats
and then my own more treats
oh that's why he's there
now you're being cute we're not taking
photos no more
silly boy
hey
hey
cutie yeah
yeah what like like have his like shower
with us first you actually want to get
him in the water though
you're so funny because look how much
i'm covered with fruit
i know there's a lot
whatever
all right so ryan just left
we got our holiday photos we got our
first holiday photo and i can't believe
it took us ten years to actually i know
i can't believe it ten years almost nine
years because our first christmas
together was 2013 i think no 2012 2012
yeah yeah yeah so nine years credit to
uh isaac for thinking of the idea to
begin with i know yeah good job baby
you thought of the idea oh you're doing
kitty litter stuff for that too yeah
good job you're doing your chore now
we're talking about doing the holiday
photos and this is all your idea oh yeah
we wanted to make it happen because it's
the last day of november
so we want to make sure we get these in
oh happy birthday by the way we didn't
vlog oh yeah your birthday at all it's
okay it's better that way though right
yeah better birthday without vlogging it
ended up being private intimate more
amazing
but i could tell you guys what i did
though it was awesome it was a really
good birthday casey surprised me in the
morning so yesterday is my birthday
right i'm now 32. casey surprised me
with flowers and breakfast in bed and it
was my favorite kind of breakfast
because it was chilaquiles and then with
some like amazing like fancy french
toast and then he tells me he was like
hey so do you have any other plans today
like is there anything in the calendar
i'm like no nothing it just says it's my
birthday it's the first day of hanukkah
and that's it and so i ended up looking
at my phone and then he actually snuckly
sneakily put it in there that um he's
surprised he's snuggling
sneakily whatever you know what i mean
that he surprised me with a deluxe
facial so at noon i ended up getting a
facial and this facial was to die for it
was amazing because they put my hands in
like paraffin wax so my hands were all
nice and soft but first they massaged it
and then they massage like my whole show
i'm usually with facials they massage
their shoulders but this time actually
went in it was like i melted and i got
to have my foot massaged too or my feet
get massaged too so that was awesome i
actually she stepped away for i don't
know how long and i woke myself up
snoring twice like that's how relaxed i
was yeah it was awesome so thank you for
that oh yeah it don't work out
i had no idea what i was doing that was
like the looks spatial sounds very
deluxe yeah it sounds pampering right
yes oh and then he was he was trying to
take me to um an italian restaurant but
isaac had a basketball thing to do
because this is this year we actually
signed him up to play basketball we're
trying to be an actual family that does
things you know like
family photos yeah
extracurricular activities yeah so
yesterday was his first like
basketball tryout thing to see which
team he could get in i don't know what
it is i'm like completely new to this
i'm not a basketball mom so because of
that reason we didn't end up going out
to eat but we did order in italian food
so we ate some of that and that was
delicious oh and then i also did i also
um yes yeah i also that's like that's
the gift you gave yourself yeah i ran
well actually you helped me you turned
on the water
um i got a really nice relaxing bath
before we had dinner so it was like a
good hour and i fell asleep in the bath
too with candles it was like a candle
lit bath it was amazing anyway that was
my birthday i had a great birthday sorry
we're gonna have any b-roll for you guys
to see but
better than bora bora though right am i
right or am i right
yeah and bora bora it was better in many
different ways for sure
but anyway so now that we're done with
this photo shoot
another thing that i'm trying to make be
a thing in this household is me cooking
so i'm gonna actually be making my first
meal
without these meal delivery kits if you
saw my video about my diet during the
pregnancy i talked about how
i've been cooking a lot recently but
it's only been through meal delivery
kits because it's like my way of like
getting my feet wet in the kitchen
because i'm completely new i mean i i
did cook when isaac was really little
but ever since casey's been in our lives
i haven't cooked so for like almost 10
years i haven't cooked recently i've
been trying to just get into the the
groove of being in the kitchen and i
just really want to be a mom in the
kitchen for my kids anyway today is the
first
meal like the first dinner that i'm
gonna be making without these meal kits
helping me and i decided i'm gonna do
like a stir-fry kind of situation
because we actually have a lot of
thanksgiving stuff left over so we have
like these cherry tomatoes we also have
collard greens
so i'm gonna saute collard greens and
cross my fingers that they come out good
because i know they're really bitter and
they're usually made in the crock pot or
whatever the slow cooker it's always
like the southern style colored greens
like with bacon and i don't know what
else but i'm just going to saute them
with some
garlic i'm also going to get some
chicken breasts slice it up stir-fry it
that's your favorite baby yep stir-fried
stuff thank you for joining the kitty
so yeah litter greens cherry tomatoes
chicken breast
and i'm gonna be making brown rice
i'm nervous even though i know i can do
this i'm really nervous because of the
collard greens like i don't know like
what if they come out really
good we're just i just have to take
risks and make it happen
[Music]
all right i just got back from the
grocery store i had a little outfit
change and i just bought some chicken
breasts they didn't have like the full
chicken breast but
i got the tenders which ends up making
my life a lot easier because i want to
slice up chicken breasts and i got the
rice going 13 minutes left dang i was
gone for a long time
so anyway i'm gonna just
whip all this stuff and call
foods ready
for dinner that's what we do that's what
we do in this house we
call that foods ready
and then we eat
you know what i just threw in the
tomatoes and i realized maybe i should
have cooked the tomatoes before the
collard greens
i'm learning am i right let me know i
don't know
[Music]
food's ready
okay familia
my first dinner without a meal kit
it smells so good like i'm like
salivating oh it looks like you're gonna
throw up no it's salivating and my
stomach's like
i know i took long sorry
it's actually it makes me kind of
emotional oh really it's very nostalgic
having someone cook for me
you haven't been feeling that way with
me cooking in the milk no
this is this is a whole new level this
is this is the ultimate level right here
this is mom's cooking yeah
kids don't count as mom's cooking that's
true because it's all like pre-portioned
and
like they tell me what to do
well
how'd they come out because i literally
did not taste anything
bomb
you think
are you just being nice
be mean though for real be honest not be
mean but be be honest
everyone may be me no i'm saying be
honest
all the greens came out perfect okay
tomatoes came out perfect chicken cooked
to perfection oh not chalky i got scared
i was like where's the bad stuff coming
chicken could use a little salt dang it
i always under salt
i always under salt i always feel like
i'm going crazy with the salt and then
it ends up being under salted but that's
that's better than being too salty you
can add your own sauce very true what do
you
think is perfect
do you like it yeah everything is good
that looks pretty great really what
happened i messed mine up already i
didn't take a picture of my wife's
cooking i know you take a picture of
everything you eat
i think you guys
are being nice but let me see let me let
me try for myself color green
okay
yeah it's really better
is it i like that flavor
it's a really colored green flavor
now i know why they stew it usually
yeah it's not dry
yeah you cooked it to perfection looking
pretty good with the chicken okay
i think you make chicken better than i
do now
really i feel like i always undercook or
overcook my chicken i never get her just
right
you're a star you're a stock hey i
wanted our plate to have color that's
why i added the tomatoes
lots of color this is pretty much my
bowl it's just have a protein a carb and
a veggie and like just switch them out
different colors it's a good way to look
at it that way you don't feel like
you're eating the same thing even though
you're essentially eating the same thing
i like it i'm proud of myself good job
too
[Music]
you